hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Shadows overloathing
we just got done uh discovering actually
that there's some dark deep entity
that's trying to destroy everything here
which is probably bad news but for some
reason I'm excited about it so let's get
back to wherever we're going I did have
hot armor and I I think you need two
one cold armor never mind maybe those
cold armor
oh I'll go there in a second I think
there might have been cold armor in um
the Cola Wars place are you Mark I'm
John Smith uh how do you know my name uh
wehobozer Italian little Community when
someone's been helping us out word gets
around well that's nice a little creepy
but nice on balance why don't you come
visit our camp we'd be glad to have you
where is it well you just had down 12th
Street till you see the lot where the
old hardware store used to be and then
you take a you know what this would be
simpler if I just mark it on your map oh
all right A D oh there it is
all right but I need to pop in here
because I need to see if there's cold
armor oh yeah the grenade I forgot about
that yeah screw all six of them two blew
up in my face two out of six isn't bad I
think I can still sell them in exchange
for your research I'll give you oh how
much of a discount 200 mean
seems uh less like a discount more like
a flat reward I just don't like doing
arithmetic all right let's see what's
for sale you got any cold armor ration
cigarettes bad for you despite what the
radio advertisements say whoa why is it
dubious maybe that's because it might
blow up in my face one in three chance
that makes sense parmesan missile
ooh culinary tactics yes so this one is
not dubious it is for realsies
but the unfortunate thing is I do not
see any cold armor I also I'm always
hesitant to sell anything mostly just
because you never know when a random
[ __ ] item will be useful in a random
[ __ ] place you hear a wet oh expired
cell C that's exactly what I'm talking
about how would I even known that I was
supposed to have that okay okay two more
of those weird fish headed guys are
rooting around the trash cans you don't
think they're the same ones as before
but since you're not usually familiar
it's hard to be sure uh
uh I mean I don't I didn't fight the
other ones maybe there's something to be
[Music]
well that's handy
[Music]
hey oh it's you if it isn't Mark nice to
see you it looks like that rumor you
heard about hobo cam turned out to be on
the level oh sure the old hobo code is
pretty trustworthy as a general rule
you're pretty good on that harmonica
thanks you want to know my secret have
only one Hobby and all the Time in the
World to practice it
all right what do we got here gab with
Gabby anything inside here nope
or my hands oh
I'm off
how in the hell did that happen hello
two goblins wearing shorts with
suspenders carrying you know those
things marching band things they're like
an upright harp except one except
instead of strings they have metal
xylophone bars
what no I don't know those things anyway
the Goblins are carrying those and they
interrupt you hello what's up you're
charging on official territory of the
Glock cleansing am I I don't know what a
glocklin is VR they're glocklins we both
we are the toughest of three gangs in
Ocean City
I don't feel particularly threatened
well that's totally incorrect I like
your xylophones though
xylophones is a glockenspiels have you
ever oh glocklins ah I'm outraged I
think we shall a mugging do all right I
don't know how this is gonna go ah
you're fine I didn't learn the other
thing that I had to do the thing oh well
who cares you're gonna
buff you're gonna buff okay well that's
not too bad
uh flap slap
foreign
[Music]
wow perfect for the heavily burdened
music lover who doesn't have a hand free
for a normal glockenspiel
a glocklin mallet ball used to be part
of a glockenspiel Mallet you can't make
music with it anymore but you could
still probably put someone's eye on
right that's pretty good now I should be
able to get through this cold which
probably is going to be something either
cool and or hilarious
all right this is this is why you don't
sell anything because you never know
when you're gonna need the fishing rod
is it gonna work please work this time
[Music]
you carefully fish the useful chemicals
out from the middle of all the dangerous
one how in the hell did I do that
Solutions precipitous tinctures you bet
got a little bit of everything in here
how did I do that pretty flower growing
out of this patch of Frosty Industrial
Waste is probably a metaphor for
something you don't understand
Damien approximately nice junk ooh
Mana charge Refrigeration coal if you
can't figure out anything useful to do
with it you could always just sell it
well I won't do that if the factory is
leaving you cold you could always leave
it is and I'd like to I think all right
back to the camp
[Music]
what did I just replace
cufflinks mysticality technically don't
I have a ranged weapon wouldn't that be
something that I would want also why am
I wouldn't why am I naked I'm very naked
oh
whoa 300 meat oh my God oh God I need to
put that in the thing
it's just wrong once per fight what does
that even mean
what does that even mean well I gotta
find out what it is plus I gotta go back
and D curse it anyway uh in particular
you notice he's sitting on top of a
mailbox he knows you too and extends xan
for a handshake you realize I'm about 30
feet away
oh it's across the street yeah but I
can't leave the mailbox sometimes I ever
grab my Curious nature but I'll ask
anyway why can't you leave the mailbox
come on over and I'll tell you all right
oh hi I'm Marvin I'm Marvin I'm Mark
what are you doing up there a stunt a
stunt it doesn't seem particularly
stunty here just sitting there yeah and
I've been sitting here for seven months
15 days nine hours and 41 minutes
to stop
protesting attracting attention nope
money contest bet nope feel like you
really don't get the concept of a stunt
and I guess not would you mind helping
me out yeah yeah
snackle cakes you want snackle cakes
nobody other than you wanted to acquire
the taste of powdered milk mixed with
sawdust and the nails still in it
because snackle Mills went out of
business years ago yeah but the shelf
life on those things is incredible it's
what makes them so good for stun rations
I got my Supply from here and grocery
down the street
all right hello knock who's there Mark
Mark who
Pierre
that is weirdly specific tiny
Tenny turn
hmm
Sylvia
boy Johnny Adam mark
change fine all right goodbye
oh God do I want to go here right away
so oh Gabby so are you new you are new
in Ocean City your first time at it
that's right what things have you got of
it well to be honest with you it seems a
little run down yes Gabby understands
you it was much nicer before an economy
happened lots of people very excited oh
oh have you seen the boardwalk yet it's
like a cat wearing pajamas
has games there and a future teller wow
I'm learning everything
I'm going now
goodbye hear hims I'll never get to
where I was who are you
you're not sure if the Lamppost is
holding up the hobo or vice versa hi I'm
what's up Dusty
hey down there on the boardwalk but that
didn't pan out why not well there's a
fellow there running a game down there
and I prefer not to step on his toes
just a matter of professional courtesy
you see and also because Carneys get
real scary about that kind of thing and
I ain't looking to be murdered anytime
soon anyway I can help well that's real
Connie I was thinking of looking for a
different Corner can you spare a nickel
for a cup of Joe and get my feet moving
uh yeah there you go I am a good egg I'm
a very good egg oh Emily lit tent
teenage girl dressed as an old woman
well that's strange tarot readings 50
mean
these prices are outrageous you could
buy sevens
oh no no just thanks all right I'll get
you in a second okay photographer if
it's more bills here's my inbox uh you
ain't the jumping Jehoshaphat baby
wherever you been all my life that face
that's exactly the face I've been
looking for it's perfect thanks I've
grown rather attached to it myself hey
you're funny too baby I love you you're
incredible listen to you know who I am
Sonya roof says Tony Fiasco hat
photographer that's right baby that's
exactly right and soon I'm going to be
the biggest half photographer in the
world city know the country know the
world I was right the first time but
there's something I need first a face a
portfolio and you know what I need
before I got a portfolio huh a face your
face baby well isn't this easy all you
gotta do is stroll in here wearing a hat
and all I gotta do is take a photograph
of that hat and now we're both gonna be
rich rich rich me with my portfolio and
you with the 30 meter I'm gonna pay you
for every picture oh well gotta be a
different app though gotta be a
different ad every time okay I ain't
paying you for the same ad twice got it
how about this hat what is that an
uncursed Fedora perfect I love it oh man
if only I'd gotten the curse Fedora I
don't think it would have been possible
to do that thanks for the me do I have
any other hats no I thought I did but I
don't
[Music]
test my everything oh
wow every winner gets a prize
but not everyone's a winner only 10 meat
newcomers start off with something
relatively easy all you have to do is
guess my age throw dart and pop a
balloon drive a nail into this board
with one swing of a hammer okay yeah
you aim the dart while winding up your
arm for a hammer swing and squinting at
the proprietor well you look about 38
but Eureka cigarette smoke so you Gaga
I'm gonna say 34. nicely done right on
the money is your prize meat shoes crab
claws makes you walk like a crab
hooray well I don't even have shoes
oh
why is that even a thing hello cooking
for Health Medical manchego
yes
I'll take that
[Music]
hot
hot hot hot
okay goodbye let me get my other hat
here
stupid hat
[Music]
fish oh
[Music]
I got it
I got a handful of cream cheese it's
cream cheese in its least convenient
form great
that's good I'll keep fishing I guess
you find an empty bag nearby that you
can use to hold any fish you manage to
reel in nice you caught a pinafore
halibut you toss it in your fish sack
you got an item fishing a sack
ah did I catch the fish or did I catch
the sack
anyway I got
I gotta fish in a sec I got a crusty
ring one wet cigarette only Optics
capable of giving you cancer in a
tapeworm at the same time great nasty
goo
I'm gonna be here a while
because I like oh it looks like you've
caught everything oh
or why I was why was I here I don't even
remember why wasn't it Gabby Gabby
didn't you want to be here Gabby why did
we come here we need to go to Heroes
hello this is Doughboy territory if you
want to walk down the street you got to
pay the toll what's the toll how about
five knuckles I don't have five meat
too bad all right fine let him beat me
up
sure
oh oh man why did I let him beat me up
hey wait a minute
uh filthy trash can dig through it you
know it baby ah a single shoe saves you
the trouble of using both feet for
walking
check for a second one there isn't the
second one fair enough
[Music]
okay all right all right bored looking
hobo lounges against a wall of crepit
building
his little dog
Muslims are suffering remember
I'm looking for here in the grocery
went out of business
oh no when
um
you've been standing here that whole
time
what are you doing here
um
went for what some work some members
remember
[Music]
I think you're gonna find any work here
considering the store is pretty
thoroughly closed I don't think you're
gonna find a word hmm bigger Northern
Star members
it doesn't look to me like another
Steward scope
um
it's me oh thank you
good luck
[Music]
that's not okay Chrome RC I told you it
was important
oh goodbye
oh
he's dork
dig through it yep
lip balm okay
huh
an empty self unless no it's empty
unless but wait
oh wait what's this what what ah there's
nothing unless unless sorry fine the
register is empty unless you know
someone who accepts mouse trap exam
currency behind the counter uh invoice
for a shipment from snackle Mills
Factory which is marked as never having
arrived the Factory's address is listed
all right good oh Rusty tongs barbecue
tongs oh that's kind of nice is it all
to do about with barbecue is that all it
is whoa that's a lot of more things than
I thought it was holy crap okay snackle
meals it is I forget what I was doing
before but I've completely forgotten uh
you look like someone who appreciates a
fine pair of pants I don't I'm naked
actually what does that even look like
dude
astute Discerning even dare I say Bruce
precious
perspicacious please put the definition
of perspicacious is that something to do
with perspiring I don't know I have
never met anyone who dared to say that
word before
listen I've got a pair of pants here
that is gonna knock your socks off I
don't know if I want that he opens his
case and pulls out a pair of slacks that
are old stiff and shiny fish your eyes
on these babies waxed slacks with these
durable wax infused trousers grease will
slide off you like grease off a duck's
leg they're waxed guaranteed greaseproof
and they're yours all right cool whoo
and that's my rent for the month dealt
with thanks pal Miss Brewster is a real
stickler Miss Brewster yeah she runs the
boarding house for that me and a bunch
of other guys stay in whenever we're in
town if you ever need a room you can do
a lot worse Miss Brewster's home for
traveling salesman I have a room but
maybe I'll check it out getting so many
locations I've barely done anything I've
just got so many locations
snuggle cakes the worst snack food ever
developed okay
oh that was easy can I have another
no
let me see what else is here
loading doors slightly ajar but what
about the front door
uh uh I can open it
looks like the abandoned Factory has
been occupied by one of ocean City's
various gangs of Street hoodlums namely
the Doughboys they're hanging out here
in the leather jackets and white aprons
bragging about their sourdough starters
and using rude words like Focaccia and
Son of a brioche or they were until you
made that huge racket getting in here
now they're staring at you and also
pointing knives at you and they're bread
knives which are serrated so you really
don't want to get stabbed with one oops
all right don't mind me I don't have any
material oh
give
give
I think I do
um
I'll be all sneaky like
oh
they seem to be aware of me over here as
well
the Dough Boys are clearly less
aggressive than other street gangs and
that they're glaring at you and
muttering angrily to each other instead
of already having attacked you however
it's also clear that you aren't getting
passed in without a fight I'm gonna get
past him with a fight
oh
well this might be a problem
how I don't have any AOE abilities do I
I'm gonna sling this at you
decrease allary the Loafer's muscle
mysticality and Moxie by 13. this is a
bad idea usable this is
a beer well I mean I gotta try it
[Music]
take that oh
it didn't seem like that bad of an idea
it seems actually pretty okay
oh yeah
I mean honestly this seems to be going
swimmingly
I don't know why anyone thought that was
a bad idea
Shadows overloathing
all right goodbye
[Music]
oh they should call you too much soup
because you just spoiled those Cooks
I don't get it
all right cool hi I killed your friends
strange that this group of Doughboys
didn't immediately attack you when you
were roughing up the other of them maybe
they don't like each other very much
well I don't like them either ow
all right
I'm getting pretty strategic about
combat
but unfortunately he's got strength
against my stank
but not that much
foreign
about cursing people with the watch was
seems to be working out pretty lovely in
fact if I took away the curse I think
that I wouldn't be able to fight as well
this is just going swimmingly for me
probably
there definitely won't be any
repercussions about this
maybe I steal their soul and it'll be
harder to cleanse the curse oh well
you left those Doughboys in the dust I
think it's flower I'm very funny I'm
extremely funny unbelievable oh this
must be the boss's office since it's the
only office
the leader of the Doughboys identifiable
by the fact that he is a greasier hat
and more rivets on his jackets than the
other Doughboys if not by the fact that
he's in a manager's office doesn't
appear to notice you when you enter he
appears to be focused on several large
piles of wet bread dough lying on the
ground around him
all right
I was just making sure I had my pants on
the boss Doughboy has not taken notice
of you yet he's probably not so density
you can get any close to him hello what
the what the hell are you what are you
doing with all these piles of dough uh
not this ain't business to use as I'm
perfecting my recipe for bread Golems
soon I'm gonna be running this town oh
yeah you and what army me and my Army of
red Gomes were you not listening I
probably shouldn't let you get away with
this
you'll be lucky to get away with all
your arms and legs rise my minions oh
god oh hold on don't do it no not my
bird
my poor bird why are you so goddamn slow
do you have to be that slow all right
but what if but what if I hypnotize you
this is
that's what you get probably I think
pretty sure that's what I want to do
oh no
it's probably totally fine slap him
Gabby thank you Gabby
oh ciabatta's pants goddamn man in Rich
flower ever since the Avenue
mass-produced magical flower the cost of
fire insurance has skyrocketed all right
I did it he's dead now forever
do I watch shabata's plans yes I do
thank you
uh you gain 68 meat and Dough Baby
recipe Quest item I don't think
anybody's giving me that question all
right let's get out of here Gabby this
was quite a side quest that we went on
nah can I go back to the
it's got the same symbols on him
interesting oh I remember what I didn't
do I gotta go back to the boardwalk of
so many things watch another location oh
I'll get to it in a second because I
didn't get my fortune told I didn't get
my fortune all right I'll pay for a
reading first guard tells us about where
you've been oh my it's the 16 of seas
what does that mean implies a piece of
unfinished business in your history I
see cows I don't remember anything like
that second card is about where you are
in the present
Jack of loaves what deck are you using
again the card indicates that you're in
a fortune teller's tent can't argue with
that last card tells the future six of
plums I see your future I see great ER
Danger
I think it's Danger
well that didn't help at all except for
plums I guess would this be better than
my
Grammy spatula it's hot damage maybe
that's good I'll give it a try okay well
that was a waste of time we gotta go
also go back to plunket street because
we gotta decursify this thing that I've
probably been randomly cursing people
with and it's probably very bad to do
such things
so I'm gonna uncursify it snorts the
pocket watch up into its Dome and begins
a strange and Loud work the pocket
watches pulled this way and that its
ticks become
and its talks becomes and it's three
ands are forcibly bent back you swear
you hear screams and then it's done
hands now at 14 11 54. now that it's
free of 10 it's just a boring regular
watch if you think about it though being
on time for things is kind of like a
magical power
all right want to project your
Consciousness into it yeah why not your
mind's eye you see the hands of a pocket
watch spin back on themselves with
jittery violence with each Revolution
the face of the watch itself expands
until it is larger than you and the
building and the street your whole world
lives in the blur of the fast running
hands in which you see your life go by
in Reverse time submarines turned along
ship cities to Stone dwellings Cowboys
to courtesians you're traveling faster
and faster to the beginning of time
itself in this no telling when this will
ride will end
I'm a dinosaur I'm a
I'm a eat the no
open the door with those two salad forks
know you lack the opposable thumbs
necessary to turn the door knob you're
completely contained in here unless you
can figure out how to open doors
I don't even know what dexterity is I
don't know anything about dexterity
rare
I won't why would I do that
check for messages there's a no for you
dinosaur no phone number hmm
uh
e open the door eat Jessica eat Charles
eat Gabby you cat uh uh I don't really
want to do those things
um how about I break down this door oh
you slap your prehistoric tummy against
the wood but it doesn't even make a dent
maybe that's why dinosaurs went extinct
uh Game Boy
ah
oh
I'm getting better
can I eat the chessboard no no no no no
no no
no
no I won't allow myself
to be done in like this I am more than a
dinosaur
unstitch the rug
eat phone
well Mark attend thy temper I tried
it
no well maybe I shouldn't have done this
damn it oh flip the dot was right there
it was right there
okay I open the doorknob oh I shouldn't
have eaten the dots too late I gotta go
back
hold on let's try that again
wait I can't undo what I did
no
no
no
no
[Music]
no
I'm sorry there's nobody I can call
anymore
oh man it wasn't me I thought I could
reset it
no
no
[Music]
wait I didn't eat Gabby wait whoa there
us what's got y'all horns and rattles
been dipping into the nose pane again
Gabby doesn't talk like that
sure is partner sure is I'm a dinosaur
I'm the quickest draw on the west sure
enough can you open the door I don't
know never had ad for puzzles got me
right funkified I didn't eat what what
strangeness of flixie never mind for the
sun Transit The Horizon and I grow ever
more ever the more in the need of a size
systems can you open these doors
curious sir for I do not believe those
doors to be locked well what do I know
and thou will find in the telephone
table hither a key to satisfied I need
okay so I'm not eating them eat that
table your stomach is bigger than your
brain and you Devour the entire table in
a few quick bites the key to the door
now lies safe and sound in your dinosaur
stomach
ah easy does it baby we're all hungry
I'm a dinosaur
door what's that Greta garbled
please tell me this isn't gonna eat the
cat oh thank goodness
ah
hey kitty kitty
Kitty
Kitty
Kitty fine
well now I'm confused real groovy pocket
watch you got there Mark I like the way
it tick tick ticks you understand me
yes a lot of power in that timepiece a
lot of power would you make a promise to
me baby would you promise not to throw
that power away a lot of good can be
done with that groovy power baby Charles
doesn't call me baby I hear you kitty
cat what do you say kitty cat will you
do me a promise promise not to throw
away the groovy power in that timepiece
ah
I don't know about that uh uh maybe it's
the only thing I have left
yeah let's do it all right Shake on it
we're shaking
you fool
you fool all right you can't relate
travel long
die Don capitas
claws making only minor holes in the
pages well now I have eight add to the
list
sounds card level help on the doc
chalkboard well I have 10 now right
don't I
sign my name oh
thank you
open door oh hi hello so we needed last
with I looking the older man though you
are far older than I shall ever be but I
never saw this room before
we are the alpha and the Omega you the
beginning of time and nights and will
you walk with me dear friend to watch
the death of our world in the birth of
another
all right
oh
oh
it's upgraded the curse is lifted time
is in its rightful home and you no
longer have a tail
I wish I had a tail
me too sometime
all right well uh
I guess I did it Charles seems
preoccupied to keep checking his pockets
lose something misplace a Chuck key to
my drill what's a Chuck key Chuckie it's
a twisty thing for tightening the chuck
on a drill kind of gotten far all right
there's a button on your map labeled
wander I just gotta wander okay
wander
Operator Operator get my worthless son
on the line I'm not a payphone that's
what the last payphone said and I'm not
buying it let me talk to my for sure son
I'm sorry sir the line is busy please
try again probably gabbling with one of
his floozy girlfriends okay
as you're walking past one of ocean
City's many disused public urinals you
notice that one's been filled up with
ice cubes as you investigate further for
some reason you notice that one of them
isn't in the Ice Cube at all but it is a
frozen Rock I am a psychogeologist I
think you wipe all the rock off examine
and then pound it into flakes I got
Frosty flakes it's like snow but in
flake form why did I do that
I'm gonna go back to Plunkett street
because I
there's so many things that I have yet
to do and I have not done and I'm so in
the middle of everything that I don't
even remember where I was I own this
place now you find Oliver ah yeah I
don't like the sound of that Oliver is
gone the handoff went extremely bad
badly yeah that too you go over the
events fancy Dan makes a variety of
faces at various points in your story
because fancy Dan is a good listener
show him the deed Oliver was carrying
this says here that ownership of the
Speakeasy is automatically transferred
to whoever has physical possession of
this deed is that legal no this is legal
oh yeah I guess you're my new boss baby
let's have one drink to more than the
old one ah good idea I guess we ought to
change the name's Place well Oliver's
place is no longer Oliver's place I
suppose that's right got any ideas well
you could go traditional just call it
Mark's Place or something hip like the
purple door or something incisive and
avant-garde I don't know no bless oblige
uh
I'm gonna call mumfler's rest in respect
of mumpler thumperdink who I have not
forgotten I just happened to forget the
name when I was starting this but it's
different people I wouldn't know yeah oh
wait no Thumper dinks drink
I almost made the worst mistake I
possibly could
thumperdincks drink
my God to business we make the beer
in-house so that's safe but we're out of
everything else and based on your story
I say the stuff at the factory isn't
safe to use if you can find booze or
mixers or garnishes bring it back here
any idea where to get started check with
Barnaby
milky-eyed sought it's that guy nose for
news in a sixth sense for Booze you
might know where you can find what
you're looking for can I have a beer
thanks
thank you
so
how about this Batoon hey your Splatoon
is kind of inconvenient nah nah baby
that's platoon isn't for spitting in
it's gone out of style now the mass
produced cigarettes are readily
available anyway that's a Bonafide
historical artifact hold on really
that's right belonged to a famous
Adventurer from Frisco just before the
turn of the century who nobody's exactly
sure a lot of people think it belonged
to Muffler humperdink it's a strong
Theory because if there's one thing we
know about that cat it's that he loved
spittoons but other people say it belong
to a fella by the name a thornlione and
a whole lot of other people claim it
belonged to a whole lot of other people
but there's one thing we know for sure
about this spatoon whoever's it was they
didn't use it for spitting into they
wore it as a hat what yeah gross right
they sure got into some weird stuff back
then yeah
weird
very weird
can I have it can I have it
can I have that
have the Hat can I have a Barnaby here
you go
this still do its Essence a lake is just
a valley abandoned they try but they'll
never damn up the flow I get it I I
understand what this is all about I
understand
okay
um well thanks all so much for
being here at bumperding strength I do
appreciate all of you that is a weird
coincidence
does it remember your last save does it
remember the achievements you've made
or did they actually put mumpler
thumperdink in here oh it'd be very very
sweet of them God I'm so behind Marvin
wrote Oh I need to wander oh what your
path unexpectedly blocked by a huge pile
of junk a broken down car busted lamp
post to couch with a Springs poking out
of it and a wide variety of other
assorted trash what happened here oh
Gabby has a memory of it there was an
accident a couple weeks ago that car had
a tire break and smashed on the lamp
post that explains the car on a lamp
post but why are they still here and
what's with the other junk City trash
takeaways are all contractors now a new
wine to pay for it nobody so the car
Waits there and people put junk there
because that's the place where junk is
Gabby you're talking really succinctly
no no not in the street that's I'll go
around it that's dangerous look at the
Lamppost for what a car can do well sure
but the traffic isn't bad right now and
hair it's not any problem Gabby starts
picking up junk and snacking it out of
the way clearing the path thanks Gabby
but it's not really Eve ha with the
mighty show of Gabby knocks a red car
over on his side Brussels it into a
parking spot wow Gabby sure showed that
car where a car goes have his muscle
increased by one great note to self
don't piss off Gabby hey here's your
[ __ ] I finally found some here you go
expert sitter you're so good at sitting
down that you make it look even easier
than a normal does thanks
I don't know how you granted me with
that but that's pretty cool thank you
for that I appreciate it I still need to
wander I don't know if I need to wander
from oh never mind
I got it
[Music]
oh a thin nervous looking man in a suit
stops you excuse me sir do you fear for
your safety in this dangerous city full
of hoodlums and criminals well I didn't
until you said that then it's a good
thing you met me I have the solution
right here oh what are you selling he
holds up a small case and opens it
displaying a selection of the tiniest
pistols you've ever seen derringers with
one of these up your sleeve in your
soccer wherever you can think to hide it
personal self-defense is right at your
fingertips are concealed pistols legal
in the state what probably sure uh how
much
30 meat I mean it's a pretty good deal I
won't regret I hey it's not a bad deal
all right here's your dumb Chuck Charles
where'd you find it under a bush all
right well that's all there's why am I
glittering why am I glowing well no time
to think about that right now I need to
go see if there's any more I can buy
here
um
[Music]
helmet that's a hat that's technically a
hat that is technically also a hat this
was apparently important for something I
don't know why smelling salts sure
sardines okay Spork sure grenade yes all
right I'm good
I do love a bugle though
I'll get it why not
hey you want to buy some [ __ ] I have a I
have some fish I got fish somewhere here
fish you want fish
there you go okay but now I can get more
money because if I go back to the
boardwalk and I wear my other hats then
I'll be able to get all the meat I need
Abby takes a piece of candy out of her
person tosses it in her mouth and holds
the first to you want one sure
thanks I guess I did hear somewhere the
Goblins processed sugar really
effectively and don't need as many
vitamins as humans jealous actually
that would be dope I love candy
ah gas mask
hello
wow wow you're welcome
and helmet
there you go
I like this this is a good job
but I like my fedori all right now with
that out of the way where the hell was I
I God I was at the hobo Camp huh it's an
unusual sight for glocklins are playing
their glockenspiels while doing some
kind of traditional folk dance it
involves a lot of skipping and hopping
and turning around in a square with
precise timing so they aren't paying any
attention to you or anyone else really
yeah join in way but you definitely
don't know the steps and would only
cause chaos oh damn it it'll be simpler
just to attack them since a brawl would
probably result anyway fine
hey
hey
stop it stop it
ship easy
[Music]
and okay easy enough
I'm getting better at the combat also
it's not on hard so it's totally fine
all right the hobo Camp guess what we're
back guys we made it here hi
Samuel
how's it going good morning
are we able to find any work
that's a shame
let's captivating you
[Music]
I don't suppose any chance of a punch
line where you really suddenly say
something really elaborate and
completely understandable
okay goodbye
uh Gabby Debbie Debbie Debbie Debbie
Debbie Debbie
[Music]
okay
hello
you must be the hobo king crown gave it
away I presume yep well you're
absolutely correct I'm the hobo King
though to foster a more familial Heir I
permanent size subjects call me Johnny
next to me you Johnny I'm Mark what can
I do for you got a question where you
from Hoboken
of course you are
don't touch that telephone really use
only this phone isn't actually connected
to anything don't let it hear you say
that okay why did I come here all right
I'm coming in here you haven't seen one
of these in ages whatever it is one
thing these notebooks have in common is
that you don't understand any of them
bewildering a way of array of partially
redacted nonsense you don't even
understand the titles of your books
music hello oh hello you must be new
here I don't think I've seen you around
my name is Mark pleased to meet you I'm
letters McCabe is there anything I can
assist you why do they call you letters
expert in microcryptography AKA hobo
code what's that system a pictographic
elements that can be written
unobtrusively on walls or carved in
defense posts Etc they're traditionally
used by Hobo's sleep messages for other
hobos to Mark a house where the
occupants are charitable for instance or
to warn of a vicious guard dog that sort
of thing I'm working on expanding the
system for more General communicating
purposes that's pretty interesting I
actually didn't know about that uh
what's the book you're reading from hobo
code manual uh teach me the basics okay
thank you because there are some letters
out there that I've seen already was the
stuff in the room stuff is a little
overboard
uh point to anything and I'll be
informative okay what is this
uh what's the machine Naval radio CR and
crypt
okay whatever I'm just gonna gloss over
these uh what's this shoebox old shoes
you're welcome
heavy boots hand-me-down boots but
they've been passed from hobo to hobo
for Generations probably about 50 pounds
of metal reinforcements on them by now
heavy boots
I don't know if that's exactly what that
is but all right desktop radio it's a
deal it's a ham radio what's it for
listen to stuff about ham all right
what's they're saying tell a type
machine we salvaged when they shut down
one of the local post office for
cutbacks patches in the local Telegraph
so we can communicate with some of the
other hobo communities heavy duty
equipment not Liberty to discuss the
details quite important if Johnny's
plans are going to come to fruition
I'll talk to Johnny about that hey
Johnny what the hell is going on in
there secret plan mine divulge alone so
will you divulge you're practically a
stranger here I apologize but I can't ah
you teach me some hobo oh according to
the hobo hobo code code I'm of course
obliged to assist but first let me test
you convince me of your worthiness
I don't even know how to be a witch How
would how how do I bewitch I don't
understand
grub
oh hello
hi they call me 52 teeth Thompson or
just 52 for short is that because of the
52 white keys on a piano nope
hobo arpeggio
ah piano I brought this baby with me on
foot how well it took a few trips
that didn't answer any questions due to
supply chain difficulty to grab cars
currently bring your own grub condiments
are still available
all right
hello folks call me Washi by the way hi
Washi all right hobo code all right hobo
code thank you for the hobo code
shut eye
shouldn't mess around here clunk Clank
Clank clunk shouldn't mess around here
client clunk stank Stomp all right well
anyway somehow I've run out another hour
doing absolutely nothing I swear I
started this episode by getting to the
hobo camp
and I'm back here again and I just now
explored it but that's what this game's
all about you find a lot of cool things
to do and they all intersect in random
weird ways so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
I'll get back to this real soon and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]